John: Good morning, Hank, it's Monday August
3rd, it's Esther Day.
You'll never guess where I've found myself.
Hank, I'm in Agloe, New York.
So Hank Agloe is here or possibly here or
possibly here; it's hard to be certain when
you're talking about a place that is only
sometimes real, so anyway here's some footage
from what I think is Agloe for Esther Day.
On Esther Day we remember our friend Esther
Earl as she wanted us to, by celebrating love
in all its many splendors.
Not just romantic love, but the love within
families and friendships.
Today is the day we say "I love you" to those
people even when it's hard, in fact especially
when it's hard.
It's also the one day a year that Hank and
I acknowledge our love for each other verbally
so OK, in accordance with Esther's wishes,
Hank, I reluctantly acknowledge that I love
you immensely.
Hank, when I've gone through challenging times
because of the bad wiring in my brain or physical
illness or whatever, it gets very hard for
me to escape the prison of my own brain.
Like the pain/fear/obsessiveness becomes so
consuming that I struggle to empathize or
listen well.
And this can become a vicious cycle, like
you're in so much pain that you become so
self-involved that it becomes difficult to
connect to anyone which in turn increases
the pain and the self-involvement and etc.
I can't tell you how many times your patience
and empathy have shut down that spiral for
me.
It's something you've done consistently for
me since you were like three.
So yeah, thank you and I just admire you a
lot and I think you're awesome and I love
you.
If you don't know about Esther, check out
her book, you can also go to dftba.com or
tswgo.org to support the charity This Star
Won't Go Out which was created by Esther's
family and provides direct support to families
of children with cancer; links in the dooblydoo.
Oh, also, I'm gonna do a question Tuesday
tomorrow Nerdfighters, so please leave me
questions, ideally brief ones, in comments.
Thank you, DFTBA.
Hank, you'll see me tomorrow.